wir kennen unsere welt nicht wir wissen
einfach nicht was da im mikrokosmos
passiert denn diese neue entdeckung von
vorstellungen am europäischen
forschungszentrum cern widerspricht dem
standardmodell der teilchenphysik denn
beim zerfall der sogenannten beauty
quarks im teilchenbeschleuniger lhc
entstanden der aktuellen studie zufolge
mehr elektronen als mio die hinweise auf
eine ganz neue physik erhärten sich
damit dramatisch klicks umsatz im juli
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
und vielen dank an peter für diesen
tollen themenvorschlag denen wir über
unser klicks um science and future
kilogramm gruppe bekommen haben der link
ist hier unter me oder in der video
beschreibung das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik ist unvollständig und
irgendetwas großes bislang unbekanntes
wartet mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit da
draußen noch auf uns physikerinnen und
physiker weltweit gehen also davon aus
dass es jenseits des standardmodells
noch teilchen und vorgänge geben könnte
die bislang im verborgenen geblieben
sind die hoffnung auf eine neue physik
ist also groß und zudem auch berechtigt
doch in den vergangenen jahren war es
eher still im forschungsgebiet der
teilchenphysik geworden fachleute
scheinen hier auf der stelle zu treten
seitdem man das higgs boson vor rund
neun jahren entdeckt hatte und somit
auch den letzten fehlenden baustein des
standardmodells seitdem wurden keine
richtigen neuen teilchen meer entdeckt
oder besonders spannende und bislang
unbekannte effekte in einen der riesigen
teilchenbeschleuniger weltweit
aufgespürt doch das könnte sich jetzt
geändert haben denn eine aktuelle
meldung vom cern lässt aufhorchen
hierbei geht es um beobachtungen die
beim sogenannten lhc experiment am cern
bei genf gemacht werden konnten also dem
experiment das large hadron collider das
in einem der vier grossen detektoren am
lhc stattfindet im ring des
teilchenbeschleunigers gibt es nämlich
nicht nur eine messstation sondern der
a4 und alle sind spezialisiert
tatsächlich konnten hier am lhc jetzt
verdächtige abweichung
im teilchen zerfall beobachtet werden
und die bringen das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik gehörig ins wanken dazu
einer der beteiligten wissenschaftler
mit spatel die potenziellen
implikationen sind so groß dass diese
ergebnisse
das aufregendste sind was ich in 20
jahren auf dem gebiet gemacht habe das
war eine lange reise um hierher zu
gelangen
ist das jetzt also der entscheidende
hinweis auf eine neue physik also worum
geht es das b hinter lhc steht übrigens
für beauty rzb also large hadron
collider beauty der entsprechenden
detector des experiments ist auf den
nachweis der sogenannten b mesonen
getrimmt denn diese enthalten die beauty
quarks die untersucht werden sollen
im standardmodell der teilchenphysik
bilden quarks die elementaren
bestandteile aus denen protonen und
neutronen aufgebaut sind im lhc entdeckt
dort finden in jeder sekunde 10
millionen proton proton kollisionen
statt wenn er läuft eine aufzeichnung
dieser zahlreichen ereignisse ist nicht
möglich denn das gibt der speicherplatz
einfach nicht her und so wird in
echtzeit entschieden welches ereignis
interessant ist dass übernimmt ein
sogenanntes trägersystem mit hilfe von
zwei filter schritten kann es
herausfinden ob ein ereignis anbieterin
enthält welches dann analysiert werden
sollte konkret handelt es sich bei dem
lhc bedeckte um einen vorwärts
spektrometer auf 20 metern entlang des
stahlrohre sind seine sub detektoren
aufgebaut seine komponenten befinden
sich auf einer seite des wechsel
wirkungs punktes um das stahlrohr
angeordnet und zwar kegelförmig am
kollision punkt befindet sich der erste
sup detektor von rcb die anderen folgen
auf einer länge von 20 metern neben
seiner länge von insgesamt 21 metern ist
er direktor 13 meter breite und zehn
meter hoch an dem experiment knapp 1200
forschende aus 16 ländern beteiligt
unter anderem auch drei institutionen
aus deutschland im großen und ganzen
geht es hier um große fragen der physik
und des lebens um materie und
antimaterie konkret geht es bei dem rcb
soll wenn darum wie protonen zerfallen
wenn sie kollidieren die fachleute
analysieren hier ganz genau wie diese
kernbausteine im teilchenbeschleuniger
mit hoher energie aufeinanderprallen
dabei entstehen kurzlebige
elementarteilchen
dabei sind auch verschiedene quarks
wieder sogenannte beauty quark beim
zerfall dieses blutig wachs entstehen
entweder zwei millionen oder zwei
elektronen die beide wiederum teilchen
typen der lehtonen sind dazu die
fachleute der rcb kollaboration nach dem
standardmodell haben die verschiedenen
rap- tonnen elektro mühen und taut die
gleichen wechselwirkung stärken das wird
als lektor universalität bezeichnet
heißt also im klartext beim zerfall von
boutique wachs müssten mit gleicher
wahrscheinlichkeit elektronen wie
millionen entstehen doch genau an dieser
stelle wurde nun die asymmetrie entdeckt
tatsächlich gab es bereits in der
vergangenheit hinweise darauf dass die
so genannte laptop universalität
verletzt werden könnte bei analysen der
protonen kollisionen aus den jahren 2015
und 2017 hatten die forschenden bereits
festgestellt dass bei den zehn fällen
leicht mehr elektronen als millionen
entstanden waren
die sogenannte lektor universalität wäre
demnach verletzt doch in den früheren
analysen waren die signifikanten nicht
groß genug um zufällige schwankungen
auszuschließen
zum verständnis in der teilchenphysik
gilt eine signifikanz von fünf als
entdeckung und das verlangt eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von 99,9999 also
jahrhundert die signifikanten der
bisherigen beobachtungen lagen um den
wert von zwei standardabweichungen sigma
also längst nicht ausreichend um auf
eine neue physik zu schließen doch bei
den aktuellen analysen steigt die
signifikanz auf 3,1 heißt also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür dass dieses
ergebnis mit dem standardmodell
übereinstimmt liegt nur noch bei rund
0,1 prozent dazu schreibt das
autorenteam das spricht für eine
verletzung der letzten universalität das
ist die bislang präziseste messung
dieses verhältnis ist doch wie oben
schon angesprochen braucht es in der
teilchenphysik fünf sigma damit es
ausreichend ist für eine offizielle
entdeckung die chance auf eine
übereinstimmung liegt dann nur noch bei
0,00 0 03 dafür müssen also noch weitere
daten des teilchenbeschleunigers lhc und
anderer beschleuniger weltweit
ausgewertet werden erst dann lässt sich
möglicherweise mit letzter sicherheit
sagen ob die leptin universalität
tatsächlich verletzt ist doch auf die
daten müssen die fachleute noch etwas
warten denn der large hadron collider
geht erst im kommenden jahr nach einer
umbauphase am cern wieder in betrieb
dann mit noch mehr power der plan sieht
vor dass dann noch mehr protonen
kollidieren und zwar zu dem auch mit
höherer energie möglicherweise können
auch die kolleginnen und kollegen aus
japan zur finalen klärung des rätsels
beitragen werden auch mit der hilfe des
japanischen teilchenbeschleunigers super
happy werden seit kurzem b mesonen in
großen mengen produziert dennoch das
neue ergebnis ist ein weiterer
erdrückender hinweis darauf dass ist
eine physik jenseits des standardmodells
geben könnte und zwar möglicherweise in
der form unbekannter teilchen oder neuer
kräfte die wir bislang nicht auf dem
schirm haben möglicherweise steckt
hinter der verletzung der elektronen
universalität eine fünfte kraft eine
wechselwirkung die die vier bislang
bekannten grundkräfte ergänzt diese
potenzielle fünfte kraft könnte wenn sie
denn dann tatsächlich existiert
unterschiedlich stark an das myon und
das electrum koppeln oder wird die
verletzung der elektronen universalität
durch ein bislang unbekanntes
elementarteilchen hervorgerufen
hier käme das sogenannte repo quark in
frage das gleichzeitig an lebten und
quarks koppelt dieses bislang noch
hypothetische teilchen könnte auch eine
erklärung dafür liefern warum die ladung
von protonen und elektronen gleich ist
natürlich abgesehen von einem
unterschiedlichen vorzeichen auch die
frage warum genau so wohl sechs quarks
als auch sechs sektoren existieren
könnte durch diese erkenntnisse
beantwortet werden das standardmodell
hat für dieses rätsel
jedenfalls keine antworten parat dazu
der lhc sprecher chris parks wenn sich
die verletzung der laptop universalität
bestätigt dann würde dieses neuartige
physikalische prozesse und interaktionen
erfordern weitere studien zu verknüpften
prozessen laufen bereits wir sind
gespannt ob sie die faszinierenden
hinweise der aktuellen ergebnisse
stärken werden es bleibt also noch eine
weile dabei wir kennen unsere welt nicht
wir wissen einfach nicht was da im
mikrokosmos passiert oder zumindest
wissen wir immer noch zu wenig die
größte maschine der welt gigantischer
plan des ncrc nachfolger der superlative
also da können dann noch mehr
erkenntnisse über die zeit für sich
gewonnen werden und vielleicht kennen
wir unsere welt dann schon in einigen
jahren besser als bisher also hier
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
abonnieren diesen kanal klicks umsatz im
future ich freue mich auf euch bis dann
bleib dran